ardan wait oh oh I thought I wasn't  gonna make it security and this place is  insane and this dick marine was like  you're not on the list and I was like  dude that's my sister space 40 feet on  your building also he took that photo of  you it's not doing him any favors  your pores are huge and no one did any  work on your eyebrows you look so angry  like that yeah you look exactly like  that  Oh what are you doing here  uh hello I thought it was pretty  appropriate for Miss Earth to see up  Earth's ambassador right what I want the  biggest patch in the world it's kind of  a big deal I mean not as big as the  space un of course the Galactic  Protectorate  you